the corona virus pandemic is forcing the
Vatican to depart from Holy Week
traditions the Vatican says the Pope
will celebrate tonight's Holy Saturday
vigil alone and he will not baptize new
Catholics into the faith this Easter
weekend many Catholics are turning to
their faith even if it means doing so
online to cope with these challenging
times Chris lives say has more a good
morning from Saint Peter's Square on a
weekend you'd normally expect to find
tourists and pilgrims by the tens of
thousands however these days hardly
anything is normal including here at the
Vatican leading up to Easter Palm Sunday
though no one to wave the Palms Good
Friday but without the pilgrims since
his inauguration he's been called the
people's Pope but a seder but in the age
of coronavirus he's the Pope with no
people as the faithful takes shelter
from a disease that this week France is
called a plague relegating to pontiff's
to self-isolation
for the first time since 1750 the Pope
walked the Stations of the Cross not at
the Coliseum but in st. Peter's Square
he also paid tribute to those who can't
stay at home doctors volunteers shop
workers and priests like the 60 who have
died and those still performing their
duties like those in NIMH bro one of the
Italian towns hit hardest by kovat 19 in
1630 the plague killed every priest in
town
now today coronavirus hasn't killed any
the priests but it's infected all but
one of them his name is Don Matteo
preaching to an ailing congregation via
YouTube he listens to the names of his
flock who have fallen victim to this
modern-day pestilence
the church has lived through trials
before he says but at least priests
could visit with their people it's so
hard for me not to see them now if
you're worried about Pope Francis the
Vatican says he's tested for coronavirus
twice negative now Pope Francis says
he's recovering from bronchitis during
Holy Week he speculated that the disease
might be nature's response to climate
change and encouraged us to look out for
the homeless who can't stay at home for
CBS this morning Saturday Chris lids say
Rome